Maybe they'll go on a Christmas date too.It's
cute.A
Christmas date.A Christmas date, right?We seem
like adults today.We're
talking, too.Yeah, let's
go.Takada-kun
probably doesn't understand that well.That's
it.  But I feel relieved
[Music]
Yes,
Kasumi-chan, Kasumi-chan, Unkasumi, my older
sister. She's my older sister's friend. She
always plays with me. She's really good at games. She's with a
guy. That's what my older
sister said.  Sister, you're going
on a Christmas date with us. We're so in
love.
[Music]
But what are you doing in a park like this? It's
cold out, so I wonder if there's a game tournament or something like that.
While we're talking and drinking, I'm going to say, "I
love you, Chammely." It
's a bad date.  But it's okay, it's okay Kasumi, your
sister is so kind
[Music] What's the matter? Nishimura-san, you
can kiss me when you grow up
[Music] Cake I
have to go buy a cake [
Music]
That's right
[Music]